hey folks I'm current Divina and I just
got the chance to see 30 minutes of
Allen week to gameplay it was hands off
but there's a lot to talk about and I
have a lot of Impressions to share with
you
before we jump right into this there's a
few things I need to clear up and that
is some stuff I love one I love Alan
awake two I love survival horror and
three I'm a big old fan of detective
mystery games and not only when they
first announce Alan Wake 2 as a survival
horde did my mind explode but what I saw
was a trifecta of all those things
because Alan Wake 2 is just as much a
survival horror as it is a detective
investigation game and that's got this
guy very excited so what I got to see
was basically an extended look at what
was revealed at summer game Fest the
gameplay I saw surrounded around Saga
Anderson and her investigating cauldron
lake with her partner Alex Casey with a
single button press Saga teleports to
the Mind place was an actual physical
room that you can move around in that
shows your evidence board as well as a
map a place to upgrade your weapons and
also do profiling which we'll get more
into in a moment as you collect evidence
you are able to actually physically
place the evidence on the wall on your
own to be able to connect your own dots
which is something I'm extremely excited
for because it feeds into my detective
loving heart so if you're not familiar
the Crux of the scheme is that Saga is
trying to find Alan Wake or at least
investigate what happened uh in bright
Falls 13 years ago and what unravels is
this big old horrific
cultist focused thing where there's
ritualistic killings and that bleeds out
into many many more Mysteries and things
that are Supernatural that of course in
one way or another align with what has
happened to Alan awake in order to
progress in the world and get more of a
connection to the dark place which is
where Alan Wake is trapped from the
first game actually connecting evidently
fine helps Saga make connections that
actually manifest things from the dark
place into reality which is what allows
the player to progress kind of allowing
this puzzle like element but of course
it's not just about the investigation
because it is also yes indeed a
full-blown survival horror I'm talking a
limited inventory inventory management
scarce resources and Incredibly Close
Quarter combat uh that was extremely
intense to watch so in the demo we saw
Saga face up against who what I assume
is one of these ritualistic killing
dudes uh wearing a face mask and even
that fight was just extremely grueling
they're intense they murmur to
themselves you also have many things in
Your Arsenal like uh one of the things
that's coming back from the first game
is flashing your light on these things
to get rid of this Darkness this this
sort of like Supernatural thing that is
shielding them which gives you an
opportunity to them shoot them open up a
spot sometimes use a flare which will
then show other weak spots for you able
to hit now for those of you who are
familiar with the first one you may know
that that's really more of an action
adventure and the combat has been
criticized for being a little repetitive
over time of just like flashing your
flashlight and a dude and then shooting
them repeat and while remedy has
vocalized they aware of that concern
that is something that kind of held the
first one back uh they're going into
this one without awareness but without
being able to play it
for the most part it did seem like that
similar routine of flashing your light
on this dude getting rid of this
darkness and then you shoot now of
course it did seem much more in close
quarters uh the flashlight like using
the flashlight seems to work even
quicker but that's kind of a good
balance considering that the enemies are
now more up close and personal also one
thing I saw there was less enemies but
they were more aggressive than they were
in the first one the first one
definitely like threw horrors of these
dudes at you while you were just like
shooting light at them shooting them
light shoot light shoot the closest
thing I can compare it to in a way is
sort of Resident Evil 2 combat
specifically because the Resident Evil 2
combat is always really up close it's in
close quarters and you're usually only
facing off a few zombies at a time but
it can still feel really dire and while
that had a similar feeling and weight in
just from what I saw I still have a
concern whether or not you know this
routine of flashlight shooting
flashlight shooting uh will actually
like stick through for an entire
campaign but of course in traditional
survival horror that also means that
there's a great deal of exploration
there's a great deal of slower pacing
especially time to build a brooding
atmosphere and also of course resource
management and some minor puzzle solving
during my time Saga saw you there was a
shotgun behind a glass case and in order
to get the shotgun you would have to
find a Post-It note that then would give
you a clue to the combination for the
lock that would then give you the
shotgun and that's like sort of like
that is the Symmetry that I'm looking
for or when I'm when I'm playing the
survival War because it kind of gives me
the agency in that I don't need to get
that gun if I don't need to but then
there's that sense of like you know
puzzle solving involved that just that
feeds into the things I love most but of
course this wouldn't be a remedy or even
an allen weight game without its
atmosphere so again this is in the
Pacific Northwest or at least the
section I saw with Saga and it is
brooding and that's where some of the
elements from control I started to see
really bleed through aesthetically there
was this fantastic part where you go
into what is called the overlap that is
where the dark place starts to feed into
reality and it's this incredible moment
of saga just like walking through a
forest with these flashing ominous red
lights that have no Source whatsoever
this tense White Noise just building uh
and it was like it's this sort of flow
of like investigating a pudding of of
putting evidence together action tense
combat but also the opportunity to
explore and let something sink in that
really really made what I saw feel
effective and kind of like the last bit
of like the whole investigative part is
of course profiling not don't only do
just peace evidence together but you
actually had the opportunity to sit at a
table with pictures of characters you've
met and you actually have to ask
yourself questions and asking the right
question will then unlock things within
saga's mind and putting herself in like
the shoes of the people she's trying to
profile profiling people is necessary to
not only gather evidence but also piece
things together so you can manifest it
from the dark place into reality and
it's just this is the trifecta I'm
talking about like The Surreal spooky
dark uh nature of the game with
investigative stuff I love it I'm a big
fan I'm excited uh but that isn't to say
it was very specific that the developers
also told me it's quirky it's a quirky
game it's retaining it's kind of Twin
Peaks isms that we saw in the first one
and that remedy just seems to have to a
T through all their games now if you're
new to Alan Wake don't worry it is not
necessary for you to play the first one
also that said it's this is a game
that's connected to remedy's other
titles like control and even Quantum
break in some small little ways but that
is not necessary like to be able to be
invested in the lore to understand Alan
Wake 2 they're being very transparent
that this should be an entry point for
anyone despite how involved you are in
remedies other games so with that being
said I only got to see a sliver of it
there's still a lot that I have to see
and thankfully uh you can actually go to
gamespot.com and we'll have a link in
the description below for my actual
written editorial piece which will give
some insight to some of the developers I
got to talk to and give a little bit
more insight but that being said this is
a game that I've been wanting to see for
13 years and it's kind of remarkable not
only see it finally happen but see it
connecting the dots in ways that just
feeds into things I really really like
but we will have to find out more when
the game releases this year on October
17th